على كل حال سال الناس في السعوديه متى
يمكنك هاجر السوشيال ميديا وممارسه سوشيال
ميديا تيتا
اذا صار عندك وعي اكثر
في السوشيال ميديا مو اي حساب تتابعه
وعندك اولويات
ومسؤوليات اكثر
تحرص عليها لانه الفاضي يطلع من برنامج
البرنامج ويروح وقت على الفاضي عليك كويسه
[موسيقى]
طبعا لازم ينقطع النت او شيء
واوقات مثلا تعب لما اصعب او شيء ما افضل
الجوال بس مش دايما بكون على السوشيال
ميديا انا احترمها لما بستفيد منها بامتنع
لما اكون مثلا قاعده مع زوجي
اصدقائي في مطعم يعني احتراما
وفي فتره هيك يعني لازم ساعه ساعتين حتى
في اليوم بعتبرها زي هيك يعني الواحد همم
لايك ميديتي مع نفسك او بتتامل
السوشيال ميديا لما تكون في لحظات سعيده
في جامعه اهل جامعه صحبات لما يكون في شيء
في بيتنا ايام العيد تلاقينا ننسى الجوال
ونقعد ننبسط بالجمعه ونتبادل الاحاديث
الوقت في استخدام مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
همم ما في بديل ولكن قد ايه يعني اقدر
اقول انها تغير او تغير طريقه استخدام او
استعمال وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
اا الصراحه امتنا على السوشيال ميديا في
اوقات مشاريع الجامعه همم طبعا لازم يكون
امتناع كليه عشان اقدر انجز الصراحه همم
برده في في التعب او قاعده التعب اوقات
السفر ممكن يكون احيانا في السفر في جمعه
الاهل في الجامعه في العمل اوقات كثيره
الواحد يحاول انه يبعد عن الجوال عن
الاجهزه